yep gigi hadid and tyler cameron are
added again so what's really going on
here
you kind of make it official now Gigi
and the Bachelorette runner-up aren't
official just yet
although the 24 year old model and the
26 year old Florida based contractor
turned model have been spending a lot of
time together recently
but doesn't mean they're ready to be
exclusive a source tells ET that for now
the pair is just casually dating quote
the two are enjoying building a
friendship first going on dates and
having fun nothing more than that right
now I mean honestly it's everything I
could ever ask for
Tyler and Gigi have good reasons to take
things slow as they both recently got
out of serious situations Gigi with ex
Zayn Malik and Tyler with Bachelorette
Hannah brown they're still feelings
there but I would support him in his
happiness I think that is the main thing
it's figuring out what will make both of
us happy Gigi and Tyler sent bachelor
nation into a frenzy after they were
spotted enjoying back-to-back dates in
New York City and earlier this week they
were seen out again with friends he
single and he can keep his options I've
been and I witnessed previously told et
that it's clear there's a connection
between them and Gigi has been smiling
more than she has in a while quote she
looks really happy and calm with Tyler
around it's like she is herself around
him it's incredible it makes everything
feel like home
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]